When we talk about language,
we often dig down to universal
categories like nouns and verbs,
consonants and vowels,
phrases and sentences.
We end up with these cross
language concepts that
individual languages are built
on almost as if the colorful diversity
found in the world's languages is just
icing on the strong unity
of the linguistic cake
and language is grounded in our way of
thinking and processing information,
which is itself universal among humans.
So languages and cultures are superficial,
but language and cognition run deep.
But this isn't the only
way to look at language.
What if the language we are brought up
to speak actually relates to the way we
look at reality from this perspective,
a language is a particular
way of conceptualizing the
world and has close ties
to culture.
In the 1930s Benjamin Lee wharf
talked about language this way.
He argued that different languages
represent different ways of thinking about
the world around us.
This view has come to be
called linguistic relativity,
exploring the grammar
of the Hopi language.
He concluded that the Hopi have an
entirely different concept of time than
European languages too,
and that the European concepts of time
and matter are actually conditioned by
language itself.
One practical consequence
of linguistic relativity,
direct translation between
languages isn't always possible.
Since hopium English aren't simply
ways of expressing the same thing in
different words.
You can't actually preserve thoughts or
viewpoints when you translate between
them
and its strongest expression.
Linguistic relativity,
the idea that viewpoint's vary from
language to language relies on linguistic
determinism. The idea that language
determines thought. In other words,
how people think doesn't just
vary depending on their language,
but is actually grounded in determined
by the specific language of their
community.
Linguistic relativity has been abandoned
and criticized over the decades with
critics aiming to show that perception
and cognition are universal,
not tied to language and culture,
but some psychologists and anthropologists
continued to argue that differences
in a language is structure and words may
play a role in determining how we think
experiments on how speakers of different
languages approach non-linguistic tasks
continue to spark this debate.
Thank you for joining me on this quick
tour of linguistic relativity and
linguistic determinism.
Please hit the subscribe button if
you'd like to keep on learning with me.